the idea that a government official like
yourself would claim unilaterally
unilaterally to represent science that
any criticism of you would be considered
a criticism of science itself is quite
dangerous
central planning whether it be of the
economy or of science is risky because
of the fallibility of the planner it
would not be so catastrophic if the
planner were simply one physician in
peoria
then the mistakes would only affect that
physician's patients the people who
chose that physician
but when the planner is a government
official
like yourself who rules by mandate the
errors are compounded and become much
more harmful
a planner who believes he is the science
leads to an arrogance that justifies in
his mind using government resources to
smear
and to destroy the reputations of other
scientists who disagree with them in an
email exchange with dr collins you
conspire and i quote here directly from
the email
to create a quick and devastating
published takedown of three prominent
epidemiologists from harvard
oxford and stanford apparently there's a
lot of fringe epidemiologists at harvard
oxford and stanford and you quote in the
email that they were from dr collins and
you you agree that they are fringe
immediately there's this takedown effort
a published takedown though you know
doesn't exactly conjure up the image of
a dispassionate scientist
instead of engaging them on the merits
even dr collins sought to smear them as
fringe and take them down
and not in journals in lay press
this is not only antithetical to the
scientific method it's the epitome of
cheap politics and it's reprehensible dr
faucie
do you really think it's appropriate to
use your 420 000 salary to attack
scientists that disagree with you
the email you're referring to was an
email
of dr collins to me if you look at the
email that you responded to and hurried
up and said i can do it i can do it we
got something in wired oh no i think in
usual fashion
senator you are distorting everything
about me did you ever object to dr
collins's characterization of them as
friends did you write back to dr collins
say no they're not fringe they're
esteemed scientists and it would be
beneath me i did not do that you
responded to him that you would do it
and you immediately got an article in
wired and you sent it back to him said
hey look i've got them i nailed them and
wired of all science that's not what
went on there you go again just do the
same thing every year that was your
response and this wasn't this wasn't the
only time so your desire to take down
people incorrect as usual senator you
incorrect almost everything well no you
deny you deny but the emails tell the
truth of this no this wasn't the only
time your desire to take down those who
disagree with you didn't stop with
harvard oxford and stanford you
conspired with peter dazak who you
communicated with privately and other
members of the scientific community that
wrote opinion pieces for nature five of
them signed a paper for nature an
opinion piece 17 signed a paper that
called it conspiracy theory the idea
that the virus could have originated in
the lab do you think words like
conspiracy theory should be in a
scientific paper
senator i never used that word when i
was referring to it you're distorting
virtually everything did you communicate
with the five scientists who wrote the
opinion piece in nature
where they were describing oh this
there's no way this could happen what's
on the lab me what i did you talk with
any of those scientists but you keep
that you keep the students the truth
to any of the scientists privately yes
you wrote the opinion you did what were
they telling you privately well let me
explain you know you're going back to
that original discussion when i brought
together
a group of people to look at every
possibility with an open mind so you not
only are you distorting it you were
completely turning it around as well
scientists that came to you privately do
they come to you privately and say no
way this came from the lab or was there
an initial impression dr gary and others
that were involved was their initial
impression actually that it looked very
suspicious for a virus who came from a
lab senator we are here
at a committee
to look at a virus now that has killed
almost nine hundred 000 people and the
purpose of the committee was to try and
get things out how we can help to get
the american public and you keep coming
back to personal attacks on me that have
absolutely no relevance to reality do
you think anybody has had more influence
let me finish this than you have you've
made a greater contest do you think it's
a great success what's happening so far
do you think you're locked down good for
our kids do you think we slowed down the
death rate more people have died now
under president biden did under
president trump you are the one
responsible you are the architect you
are the lead architect for the response
from the government and now 800 000
people have died right do you think it's
a winning success what you've advocated
for government
senator first of all
if you look at everything that i said
you accuse me of in a monolithic way
telling people what they need to do
everything that i've said
has been in support of the cdc
guidelines wear a mask
get boosted and you've added advantage
to make it course take a look at
everything
to be done by mandate but you've
advocated that your infallible opinion
be dictated by law all right so again
madam chair i would like just a couple
of minutes because this
this happens all the time you personally
attack me
and with absolutely not a shred of
evidence of anything you say so i would
like to make something clear to the
committee he's doing this for political
reasons what you need to do
is he said in front of this committee do
you think your takedown i was prominent
epidemiologist was not political
paul if you would please um i'm going to
allow this uh dr fatchi to respond we
have a number of senators who would like
to ask questions and i would like him to
be able to respond please do so
the last time we had a committee of the
time before he was accusing me of being
responsible for the death of five four
to five million people which is really
irresponsible and i say why is he doing
that there are two reasons why that's
really bad
the first is it distracts from what
we're all trying to do here today
is get our arms around
the epidemic and the pandemic that we're
dealing with
not something imaginary number two
what happens when he gets out
and accuses me of things that are
completely untrue
is that all of a sudden that kindles the
crazies out there and i have life that
threats upon my life
harassment of my family
and my children with obscene phone calls
because people are lying about me
now you know i guess you could say well
that's the way it goes i can take the
hit
well it it makes a difference because as
some of you may know
just about three or four weeks ago on
december 21st
a person was arrested who was on their
way from sacramento to washington dc
at a speed stop in iowa
and they asked the police asked him
where he was going
and he was going to washington dc
to kill dr fauci and they found in his
car
an ar-15 and multiple magazines of
ammunition
because he thinks that maybe i'm killing
people so i ask myself
why would senator want to do this
so go to
rand paul website
and you see
fire dr fauci with a little box that
says contribute here you can do five
dollars ten dollars twenty dollars a
hundred dollars so you are making a
catastrophic epidemic for your political
gain so the ownership politically
attacked your colleagues and in a
politically reprehensible
things like the reputation okay we won't
defend it no don't argue it i'm just
simply turn around continue this hearing
we have a number of questions
one one more minute please dr patchy i i
really appreciate your response but we
do have a number of questions from
senators and we do have a second round
and i'm being asked to make sure that
everybody has their time so thank you
thank you very much for allowing me
madam chair